네. 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다. 어,
저희가 3월 한 달 동안 중계한
거래액이 무려 1,400억 정도
됩니다. 그래서 저도 되게 놀랐는데
지금 사실 빌딩 시장이 좋지 않아요.
그래서 전체적으로 빌딩 거래 건수를
보면 많이 줄어들었습니다. 어떤
지역이 거래되고 어떤 빌딩들이 좀
거래되는지 좀 설명을 해 드리려고
합니다.
빌사남의 노크.
일단은 저희가 1400억 정도 했는데
한 50%는 다 강남 지역에 있는 거
같아요. 뭐 세부적으로 동을 보면
신사동이나 뭐 청담동, 노년동,
역삼동 이쪽 위주로 좀 거래를
했습니다. 그래서 그 거래 건수가 한
50% 정도 되고 그리고 조금
특이한게 성수동이 거래 건수가 좀
많았어요. 그래서 요즘에 뭐 성수동이
워낙 인기가 많다 보니까 성수동이 한
30% 그리고 나머지 20%가 여기
마포구 내에서 홍대 입구역 근처
합정력 근처 이쪽으로 좀 거래가
됐습니다. 팔리는 지역만 팔리는 거
같아요. 정말 괜찮은 건물 위주로 좀
거래가 됐고 그리고이 거래된 건수
중에 좀 근매가 하나 있었는데
감정가보다 무려 100억이 저렴하게
거래가 됐습니다. 산 가격보다 더
저렴하게 파는 건물도 있었는데 이렇게
자금을 가지고 계신 분들이 이게
감정가보다 엄청 낮게 거래가 되거나
이런 매물로 나와 있는 건물들을 직접
매입하고 있는 거 같아요. 전체적으로
빌딩 건수는 줄었지만 살려는 사람은
지금 계속 사고 있다. 어 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그리고 거래
금액대로 보면 금액대가 좀 많이
높아졌어요. 우리가 꼬마 빌딩
규모보다는 금액대가 좀 높은 건물
위주로 좀 거래가 됐고 한 건의
평균적으로 금액이 한 200억 정도
됩니다. 그래서 금액대가 좀 많이
높아졌고 지금 담보 대출 금리가
그렇게 높진 않아요. 어 최근에
저희가 담보 대출 금리 나갔던게 보통
이제 3% 대가 많이 나왔습니다.
지금 빌딩 매입하기에는 되게 좋은
시기이긴 하지만 지금 임대 시장이
좋지 않기 때문에 확실한 거만 지금
거래가 되는 거 같아요. 진짜 임대가
확실히 차이거나 확실한 위치에 있거나
뭐 이런 건물 위주로 좀 거래가 됐고
개발하려는 건물보다는 이미 완성이 돼
있거나 리모델링만 하는 되는 그 정도
건물만 거래가 된 거 같습니다.
요즘에 뭐 신축이 사실 좀 쉽진
않거든요. 뭐 건축 비용도 많이 들고
건축 기간도 워낙 많이 들기 때문에
웬만하면 좀 완성돼 있는 건물 위주로
거래가 된 거 같습니다. 거래량이
조금 더 늘어날 것으로 좀 예상이
되는데 지금 3월 달 거래된 것처럼
확실한 지역만 매각이 되고 있습니다.
그래서 저는 고객분들한테 항상
말씀드리는게 확실한 지역 아니면 그냥
빌딩 사지 말라 그러거든요. 나중에
팔리지도 않고 임대도 안 되고
애물단지가 되는 경우 워낙 많거든요.
그래서 여러분들이 지금 시기에 빌딩을
매입한다라고 하면 확실한 지역에 있는
빌딩만 보셨으면 좋겠습니다. 그래서
저는 앞으로 양극화가 더 심해질 거
같아요. 오르는 지역은 계속 오르고
안 되는 지역은 계속 안 될 겁니다.
그리고 중간이 없어졌어요. 요즘에 막
이렇게 영상들 보다 보면 돈 없이
건물 살 수 있다. 그런 광고들이
되게 많은데 저는 되게 위험한
행위라고 생각하거든요. 제가 아까
말씀드렸다시피 저희가 사실 빌딩
투자하는 이유가 다 나중에 시세 차익
보고 투자를 하는 건데 애매한 지역에
건물 사면은 건물 매각이 안 됩니다.
정말 내가 셋던 금액보다 더 싸게
내놔야 될 수도 있어요. 그리고
앞으로 저는 양극화가 더 심해질
것으로 예상이 되기 때문에 여러분들은
반드시 빌딩 사신다 그러면 잘 팔리는
지역에 어 건물을 사셨으면
좋겠습니다. 그래서 뭐 예를 들면
이럴 거 같아요. 제가 만약에
50억짜리 건물을 산다라고 하면은
서울시 내에서 50억대 건물이 제일
많이 팔리는 동네를 가야 돼요.
그렇게 돼야지 나중에 그 건물이
팔기가 되게 쉽겠죠. 워낙 요즘에 뭐
수익률 많이 나온다. 뭐 인차인이
너무 좋다, 뭐 해 가지고 외곽에
잘못 투자하는 경우가 많은데 빌딩의
가장 큰 핵심은 황금성입니다.
물고기가 있는데 낚싯대를 넣어야지
물고기가 잡힙니다. 물론 경쟁자가
많더라도 사람이 많다고 사람 없는데
잘못 낚싯대 넣었다가 나중에 팔리지도
않고 시간만 허의하는 경우 되게
많습니다. 결론은 사람이 많더라도
거기다 낚싯대를 넣어야 된다. 어,
이게 결론입니다. 네. 네. 그래서
일단은 제가 3월 달 매각 살해
가지고 좀 설명을 드렸고 앞으로 좀
매각되는 건물이라든지 매각되는
지역이라든지 이런게 데이터가 좀 더
쌓이면 제가 그 데이터를 토대로
영상을 한번 다시 찍어 보도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하겠습니다. 빌딩은 역시 빌사함.